[Music]  this mosques distinct red and white  patterns and tall minarets can be seen  from every part of this Sri Lankan town  [Music]  Jamal afar known locally as the red  mosque is located in Colombo Sri Lanka  it was commissioned in 1908 by Indian  Muslims who traveled for business and  needed a place of worship while in Sri  Lanka the designer and builder was HL  saber lab and the original structure  only took one year to build and was  completed in 1909 he was influenced by  Indy Sarah scenic architecture which is  a hybrid of Indian and Islamic styles  the best example of this is the mosque's  pomegranate shaped domes the mosque  started small only 500 to a thousand  people gathered but it has since grown  and expanded to be six floors to  accommodate around 10,000 worshippers  apart from being a major tourist  destination for visitors Jammu lava is  also the main place of worship for Sri  Lankan Muslims  [Music]